schauen wir aber in die ukraine der
krieg der tobt dort weiter besonders im
donbass und jetzt nennt präsident
selensky die situation dort im besonders
beängstigend gleichzeitig hat er ein
ganz klares kriegs ziel gesetzt er will
die krim zurückerobern
heute ist der 110 der tag unserer
verteidigung ist der 110
daran erkennen sie was für einen weiten
weg zurückgelegt haben der feind wurde
aus den gebieten
schizophrenie und zum vertrieb ein
großer teil der region krake wurde das
freieste insgesamt wurden mehr als 1000
lose it bereichen der einmarsch der
besatz zu einem süßen der ukraine wurde
gestoppt ja sie wollen immer noch nicola
borussia und die städte der region micro
zerstören aber dutzend sie von
angriffsversuchen der russischen armee
sind bereits im süden vereitelt worden
und dank der gegenoffensive hausen
einige orte in der region kers von
bereits befreit trotz des erheblichen
vorteil der russen in bezug auf
ausrüstung mit artillerie romantik ist
dann besonders dramatisch ist die
situation derzeit in sphären es dort
droht die einkesselung die letzte brücke
dort wurde zerstört die seit wochen
umkämpfte stadt im osten der ukraine ist
damit nahezu vollständig von russischen
truppen eingekreist aktuell halten sich
dort immer noch 10.000 menschen auf die
nicht rein nicht rauskommen was passiert
mit den soldaten auch dort sind sie
haben laut eduard war syrien der sich
stellvertretender leiter der donezker
volksrepublik anons genau zwei
möglichkeiten
der republik in der gegend von oslo ganz
finden schwere gefechte statt wir haben
uns der stadt bereits teilweise genährt
sie wissen auch dass sich der garonne
jetzt gekämpft wird mit zugang nach
lucia wäre doch jetzt ist eigentlich
blockiert nachdem gestern die letzte
brücke gesprengt wurde die ukrainische
militäreinheiten die dort stationiert
sind bleiben daher für immer dort sie
haben zwei möglichkeiten entweder sie
folgende beispiel ihre kollegen und
ergeben sich oder sie sterben sie haben
keine andere möglichkeit ich kenne
diese situation sie erinnert an die
situation im also stahlwerk der hölle
von mario pohl wochenlang zivilisten und
kämpfer eingesperrt waren in den
katakomben jetzt gibt es einen ersten
blick dort hinein in diese hölle in das
stahlwerk man von außen sieht man die
zerstörung das ausmaß der zerstörung und
wenn man die bilder von innen sieht kann
man sich vorstellen wie die menschen
dort ausgeharrt haben dort gelebt haben
ihnen drinnen die katakomben ohne
trinken ohne essen dort betten gebaut
aus ein paar brettern die herumliegen
dort wurden operationen durchgeführt
beispielsweise bein amputiert ohne
jegliche betäubung dort gab es teilweise
nur noch ein glas wasser zu trinken pro
tag auch kinder hatten dort raus hatten
dort aus die hölle des stahlwerks und
wir müssen über noch eine hölle sprechen
butscher der kleine ort nördlich von
kiew wurde wie kaum ein anderer zum
zeichen der
unvorstellbaren brutalität der
unvorstellbaren kriegsverbrechen kein
anderer ort in der ukraine verdeutlicht
die brutalität das leid und das unrecht
welchen die menschen in der ukraine seit
putins überfall auf ihr land dulden
müssen während internationale
ermittlungen zu den kriegsverbrechen
laufende bestreitet moskau nach wie vor
jede verantwortung will vize paul
ronzheimer war damals als einer der
ersten westlichen journalisten dort vor
ort berichtete von diesen grauenhaften
geschehnissen hier beispielsweise
zivilisten die vom fahrrad geschossen
wurden weil sie einkaufen gehen wollten
zivilisten denen die hände auf den
rücken gebunden worden die hingerichtet
wurden es macht einen fassungslos und
jetzt ist paul ronzheimer zurückgekehrt
zurückgekehrt an diesen ort des grauens
es ist der dritte april ein kalter
verregneter sonntag ein tag an dem sich
der welt das grauen von putins blutigen
krieg gnadenlos offenbart das massaker
von butscher mitten in der hölle trifft
paul ronzheimer irena vor ihrem haus nur
wenige tage zuvor muss sie mit ansehen
wie ihr mann oleg von russischen
soldaten misshandelt und ermordet wird
wie so vielen anderen unschuldigen
opfern in butter binden putins killer
seine hände hinter dem rücken zusammen
verbinden seine augen und zwingen ihn
sich hinzuknien dann strecken sie in
kaltblütig mit einem kopfschuss nieder
das alles vor irinas augen alex leiche
liegt zu diesem zeitpunkt noch immer vor
dem haus nachbarn bedecken den leichnam
provisorisch mit plastikplanen heute
knapp zwei monate später trifft paul
ronzheimer irena wieder immer wieder
bricht sie in tränen aus blickt auf das
von den russischen soldaten völlig
zerstörte haus
ich weiß nicht wie es weitergehen soll
ich bin am ende ohne mein mann wird mein
leben nie wieder so wie früher sein
so wie irena geht es hunderten familien
im winter männer die während der
russischen besatzung willkürlich in
ihren häusern oder auf der straße
hingerichtet wurden in dem ort der auf
so grausame weise welt bekannt wurde hat
sich rumgesprochen dass bundeskanzler
olaf scholz zusammen mit frankreichs
präsident makro und italiens premier
draghi nach kiew reisen wird in wenigen
tagen soll wohl der deutsche
bundeskanzler olaf scholz nach kiel
kommen was würdest du ihm gerne sagen
es ist sehr gut dass scholz in die
ukraine kommt ich möchte dass er besser
besucht und mit leuten wie mir spricht
die menschen in deutschland müssen die
wahrheit erfahren und dass wir hilfe
brauchen
ich möchte dass er putin sagt dass er
ein lügner ist hier gab es keine
schaufensterpuppen und wir sind keine
künstler sowie die russen propaganda
behauptet wir sind alles echte menschen
ob scholz auch butscher besucht ist
bislang nicht klar wenn er in den vorort
von kiew kommen sollte der zur hölle
wurde dann wird er einen ort besuchen
der von außen schon fast wieder normal
wirkt in den straßen in denen die
leichen lagen flanieren frauen und
kinder die trümmerberge sind aufgeräumt
[Musik]
doch der schmerz wird immer bleiben
es wird nie mehr so werden wie früher
früher hatte ich mein mann ist und jetzt
ich bin ihnen so dankbar für alles jetzt
muss ich versuchen alleine
zurechtzukommen
auch ihm zuliebe
hier zwischen 1 0% von daten wird
[Musik]
paul ronzheimer mir jetzt zugeschaltet
aus hier fall paul die menschen jetzt
sehen wir dich ich glaube jetzt höre ich
leider diese schalten nicht
funktionierte arbeiten wir natürlich
dran wir bauen das nochmal auf und da
bist du jetzt auch paul zugeschaltet aus
kiew berührender berichte aus butscher
man kann sich nicht ausmalen wie es den
menschen trotz der trauer trotz des
schocks trotz der bilder die sie
vermutlich nie wieder los werden gelingt
weiter zu leben einfach weiter zu machen
was mit irina gesprochen schilder und
einmal was du dort in butter jetzt
nachdem diese kriegsverbrechen dort
geschehen sind empfunden gesehen erlebt
hast
also berührt immer noch von dem was
passiert ist
war das grausamste natürlich was sie in
ihrem leben gesehen hat als wir man vor
ihren augen hingerichtet wurde als sie
das mit ansehen musste und jetzt wird
wieder hinzukommen und diese frau zu
sehen die immer noch völlig unter schock
steht nach diesen zwei monaten ihr haus
zerstört wie immer wieder an dem platz
zeigt wo ihr mann hingerichtet wurde das
war etwas ja kaum fassbares in diesem
moment verfügt wird
und dann ist ja ein wunsch formulierte
mit diesem wunsch ist sie sicherlich
nicht alleine sie sagte wenn jetzt olaf
scholz nach in die ukraine reist dann
soll er hierher kam er soll sich das
anschauen er solle auch putin sagen dass
er ein lügner ist wie viele wünsche
dieser art gibt es wohl seitens der
menschen in der ukraine und wie viel
dieser wünsche wird olaf scholz deiner
meinung nach erfüllen
es wird schwer für olaf scholz
diese wünsche zu erfüllen vertriebs wir
doch dass ich ganz klar ob es
tatsächlich nachgekommen wird er wird
jedenfalls definitiv seien mit masken
tragen dass wir der nur dem event
treffen und dann möglicherweise so war
es bei anderen regierungschefs eben
tatsächlich dann nach gut fahren oder
nach alpin oder in einen weiteren ort
und die menschen in butter die sind zum
einen darauf dass olaf scholz die
realität sieht dass er sieht was dort
wirklich passiert ist dass er mit den
menschen spricht das macht natürlich
diesen unterschied und auch sicherlich
das emotionale gefühl wenn man dann vor
einer frau wie irina steht sie hat
gesagt ja komm her
bundeskanzlers und ich erzähle dir was
mir passiert ist das hat sie ganz klar
formuliert
unabhängig davon schauen die menschen
dort in butter natürlich auch in den
osten denn sie wissen dass dort
möglicherweise in anderen orten das
passiert in diesem moment patricia was
damals in butter passiert ist und da
sagen sie brauchen diese menschen
dringend hilfe sie sagen da müssen
endlich mehr waffen hin damit die
ukraine sich verteidigen wird ja auch
präsident zielinski nannte die
entwicklung im donbass beängstigend und
gleichzeitig hat er war in der
vergangenen nacht auch ein ganz klares
kriegsziel definiert er sagte wir holen
uns die krim zurück da spricht schon
auch dafür dass die ukraine bereit ist
diesen kampf ganz erbittert
weiterzuführen gleichzeitig wird auch
dann beim besuch von scholz klar werden
dass es auch dort auf unserer seite
forderungen gestellt werden dass
forderungen gestellt wenn das man zu
einem kompromiss kommt was glaubst du
wie schnell wie hoch schätzt du die
kompromissbereitschaft nach all dem was
die ukraine erleben musste in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten ein
ich sehe momentan keine chance dass die
ukraine sagt okay wir sind bereit auf
bestimmte gebiete im osten im donbass zu
verzichten so die messe lenski das muss
man so ehrlich formulieren ist da auch
immer unterschiedlich in seiner
kommunikation jetzt spricht er wieder
von der camp in vor einigen anderen
wochen hat er das ziel formuliert dass
man bis zur linie des 24 erst mal zurück
will natürlich ist das ziel der ukraine
das gesamte territorium zu erobern es
ist für sie lenski auch psychologie
gerade in einem moment wirklicher weise
wo die ukraine eben im osten so viele
menschen verliert so viele soldaten
sterben versucht er der bevölkerung dort
mut zu machen und zu sagen unser ziel
bleibt auch die krim also das gesamte
territorium
das ist natürlich in solchen momenten
wie gesagt immer psychologie und der
präsident versucht seine menschen die
menschen die bevölkerung darauf
einzuschwören dass es weiter geht und
gleichzeitig gibt es jetzt situationen
wie beispielsweise ins werden es wohl
die letzte brücke zerstört wurde und
damit auch die einkesselung droht und
wie schätzt du diese situation ein mario
pohl butscher all das grauen was wir
gesehen haben es scheint so als würde es
immer brutaler werden in diesem krieg
die lage im osten ist absolut dramatisch
betritt ich habe dort
mit menschen sprechen können mit
kommandeuren sprechen können die wir
zuletzt vor fünf sechs wochen getroffen
haben schon damals haben sie mir erzählt
wir haben zu wenig munition
wir haben zu wenige artillerie wir haben
gar keine chance gegen diese russischen
truppen bei 800 schuss der russen können
wir gerade mal 50 dem entgegensetzen das
war die relation das wird immer
deutlicher natürlich fragt man sich wie
kann das eigentlich sein wenn diese
munition mangel schon vor sechs bis acht
wochen so klar war warum ist das immer
noch so wieso kommt diese hilfe
entweder nicht schnell genug an die
front oder es ist nicht genügend da
deswegen wird das natürlich ein großes
thema sein für sie lenski bei dem besuch
der drei staatschefs und mit klar machen
wenn es nicht mehr hilfe gibt dort im
osten dann beruht die ukraine dort zu
verlieren und das ist ja dann nur der
erste schritt dann wird es so gehen die
experten davon aus so geniale mehr
ukraine davon aus dass dann putins
truppen wieder versuchen werden weitere
großstädte anzugreifen wie sony profi
oder des darunter möglicherweise wieder
hier zurück versuchen zu kommen vertritt
sie nach kräften keiner glaubt dass
putin nach lukas und dem bass einfach
aufhören sagt paul ronzheimer uns
zugeschaltet aus kiel vielen herzlichen
dank paul für deine informationen an
diesem morgen